This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Item 4 is actions on special orders of the day that typically proceeds with the Council member announcements. What you're hearing is an Oakland, California city council meeting that took place in July of 2014. There's a whole bunch of different issues on the agenda, everything from allegations of funds being misused. We know that there was a lot of manipulation of funds, okay? And there's been a big ripoff with those funds to announcements of neighborhood parties. Basketball, pickup game, field game, space painting, zoom dancing. And producer Mickey Capra sat to the entire meeting like a good reporter does.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。第4项是关于特别议程的行动，通常在市议员公告之后进行。你现在听到的是2014年7月举行的一次加利福尼亚州奥克兰市议会会议。议程上有许多不同的议题，从资金被滥用的指控，到社区聚会的公告，应有尽有。我们知道资金确实存在大量操纵，好吧？这些资金被严重挪用。篮球、接球游戏、场地游戏、空间绘画、变焦舞蹈。制作人米奇·卡普拉像一位优秀的记者一样，全程参加了这次会议。
To hear them say this. Move the item president moved by vice mayor read second by miss mackle handy and by consensus will adopt the items in the consent count so they never actually say it directly but by adopting the items in the consent calendar what happened there is that the city of oakland finally legalized for the first time since the 1930s. Pinball machines. I'm Michael Shees on the founder and executive director of the Pacific Pinball Museum.
听听他们是怎么说的。主席动议，副市长里德动议，麦克·汉迪女士附议，经协商一致，我们将通过同意议程中的项目。所以他们实际上从未直接说出来，但通过通过同意议程中的项目，奥克兰市自20世纪30年代以来首次将弹球机合法化了。我是迈克尔·希斯，太平洋弹球博物馆的创始人和执行董事。
The Pacific Pinball Museum, which is a collection of really cool, mostly older machines that you can still play, is in Oakland's neighboring city, Alameda. Until recently, coin-operated pinball machines were also illegal in Alameda. And it's the reason that we started out as an admission-based establishment and everything was on free play. Most of the museum's pinball machines look a lot like the ones you've seen before in your local bar. But there are a few really old ones that look completely different. And pinball's design history can help explain why it was illegal for so long and why after nearly 80 years of being a slightly sketchy leather jacket wearing Nurdwell, Pinball can now go legit and claim its place with Pac-Man as good clean family fun.
太平洋弹球博物馆收藏了许多非常酷、大多是较旧的机器，你仍然可以玩，它位于奥克兰的邻市阿拉米达。直到最近，投币式弹球机在阿拉米达也是非法的。这就是我们最初作为一家基于门票的机构，并且所有机器都免费玩的原因。博物馆里的大多数弹球机看起来和你当地酒吧里见过的差不多。但也有一些非常古老的机器，看起来完全不同。弹球的设计历史有助于解释为什么它被禁止了这么久，以及为什么在经历了近80年作为略显可疑、穿着皮夹克的“书呆子”之后，弹球现在可以合法化，并与《吃豆人》一起占据一席之地，成为一种健康、纯净的家庭娱乐。
Pinball evolved out of a game that was also played in a tilted cabinet, but was a bit more like Billiards. You'd shoot the ball onto the field with a pool stick. In the 1860s, the pool queue turned into a spring loaded plunger that you'd pull and release to launch the ball. They were simple wooden boards with glass tops, no electricity, no flashy art or colors. And the game was made small to fit on top of a counter at a bar or drugstore. The mechanics of the game were simpler too. You basically did one action, pull the plunger. The ball would shoot up the rights of the board
弹球是从一种同样在倾斜柜中玩的游戏演变而来的，但更像台球。你会用台球杆把球射入场地。在19世纪60年代，台球杆变成了弹簧驱动的柱塞，你可以拉动并释放它来发射球。它们是简单的木板，顶部有玻璃，没有电力，没有华丽的艺术或颜色。游戏被做得小巧，可以放在酒吧或药店的柜台上。游戏的机制也更简单。你基本上只做一个动作，拉动柱塞。球会射向木板的右侧
and onto the play field, where there were. Little pockets that would catch the ball, and then they were usually stamped with the point value. And there were pins, which looked like tiny nails that obstructed your way into the pockets. That's where pinball came from, was the nails or the pins that were driven into the board.
进入游戏场地，那里有小口袋可以接住球，通常上面印有分值。还有销钉，看起来像细小的钉子，阻碍你进入口袋。这就是弹球的由来，即钉入木板的钉子或销钉。
And the first games weren't coin-operated. Bars would buy one. And they would rent it out to people that wanted to play it and gamble with it. It was kind of like renting out the card table. By the 1930s, Pimmel games were coin-operated. And you'd find these little countertop games all over the place. And bars and drugstores. You know, you'd buy an egg cream to drink and some horrible tasting elixir at the local drugstore, and you'd use your change to play some pinball. And maybe
最初的游戏不是投币式的。酒吧会买一台，然后租给想玩和赌博的人。这有点像出租牌桌。到了20世纪30年代，弹球游戏变成了投币式的。你会发现这些小型的台面游戏随处可见。在酒吧和药店里。你知道，你会在当地药店买一杯蛋奶饮品和一些味道糟糕的药剂，然后用剩下的零钱玩弹球。也许
you'd win a pack of gum or cigar, and you'd have fun doing it. Then it moved to just straight up gambling. Where instead of being awarded a prize, you were given cash. And it's around this point that Pinball became electric. Lights and buzzards started showing up, along with other stuff like bumpers that you could bounce off of to get more points. Points that needed to be tallied up on a scoreboard, which led to what is now referred to as the back glass, that's the part of the pinball machine that faces you as you play. And the art on the back glass became one of the most iconic things about the pinball machine.
你会赢一包口香糖或雪茄，玩得很开心。后来它变成了纯粹的赌博。你不再获得奖品，而是获得现金。就在这时，弹球变得电动化了。灯光和蜂鸣器开始出现，还有其他东西，比如可以弹开以获得更多分数的保险杠。这些分数需要在记分牌上统计，这导致了现在所说的“背板玻璃”，也就是你玩游戏时面对的那部分弹球机。背板玻璃上的艺术成为了弹球机最具标志性的特征之一。
On the newer games, a lot of the art is licensed from movies, like the 1991 hit blockbuster The Atoms family. But if you go into the pinball museum in Alameda, almost all the old games from the 30s and 40s were done by one of two artists. So George Mollentin and Roy Parker. The art was meant to appeal to men and boys. So a lot of it features pictures of pretty ladies. The back glass of a game called marble queen
在较新的游戏中，很多艺术都是从电影中获得授权的，比如1991年的热门大片《亚当斯一家》。但如果你走进阿拉米达的弹球博物馆，几乎所有30年代和40年代的旧游戏都是由两位艺术家之一创作的。乔治·莫伦廷和罗伊·帕克。这些艺术旨在吸引男性和男孩。所以很多作品都以漂亮女士的图片为特色。一款名为“大理石女王”的游戏的背板玻璃
depicts a group of women in swimsuits and high heels gathered around in a circle, plain marbles. They're surrounded by a big tall fence, almost like they're in a clubhouse. You see the guys that are picking through the fence and it's pretty funny. The ultimate fantasy of a boy from the 1930s was women in their bathing suits, playing marbles. The lights and buzzers and women in bathing suits just made you want to put more and more money into the machines. Sometimes people were just playing a win-a-free game, other times there was a bigger payout, but it all added up.
描绘了一群穿着泳衣和高跟鞋的女性围成一圈玩弹珠。她们被一圈高高的栅栏围住，就像在俱乐部里一样。你可以看到那些透过栅栏偷看的家伙，这很有趣。20世纪30年代男孩的终极幻想就是穿着泳衣玩弹珠的女性。灯光、蜂鸣器和穿着泳衣的女性让你想往机器里投入越来越多的钱。有时人们只是为了赢取免费游戏，有时会有更大的回报，但这一切都累积起来了。
These things made a ton of money. I can't emphasize enough of that because the mafia got involved it was all cash. With so much money disappearing into pinball machines the authorities started cracking down. It really got heated in the forties. More and more laws were being enacted to make pinball gambling harder. Manufacturers would try to get around this by labeling the machines. It says right here, for amusement only, no prizes, no wagering. I mean, they put that right on the machine, and everybody knew that, well, that's exactly what it was for. By the end of the 1940s, pinball was banned in most major cities, including Chicago and Los Angeles. But perhaps nowhere was the pinball crackdown so extreme as in New York City, where in
这些东西赚了很多钱。我怎么强调都不为过，因为黑手党介入了，而且全是现金。随着这么多钱消失在弹球机中，当局开始严厉打击。这在四十年代变得非常激烈。越来越多的法律被制定出来，使弹球赌博变得更加困难。制造商试图通过给机器贴标签来规避这一点。上面写着：仅供娱乐，无奖品，无赌注。我的意思是，他们直接把这个写在机器上，每个人都知道，好吧，这正是它的用途。到1940年代末，弹球在大多数主要城市被禁止，包括芝加哥和洛杉矶。但也许没有哪个地方的弹球打击像纽约市那样极端，在那里
1942, Mayor LaGuardia ordered the NYPD to round up all of the machines. Then, in a press event, the mayor personally shattered some of the machines with a sledgehammer and had them dumped into the Hudson River. LaGuardia later reported that 2000 new police Billy clubs would be made from the wooden legs of old pinball machines. Perfect for knocking the heads of pinball plane hooligans. Mayor LaGuardia did not succeed in ridding the world of pinball entirely, though. It was still legal in some cities, and even in New York, it didn't totally disappear.
1942年，拉瓜迪亚市长下令纽约警察局搜缴所有机器。然后，在一次新闻发布会上，市长亲自用大锤砸碎了一些机器，并将它们倾倒在哈德逊河中。拉瓜迪亚后来报告说，将用旧弹球机的木腿制作2000根新的警察警棍。非常适合敲打弹球流氓的头。不过，拉瓜迪亚市长并没有成功地将弹球从世界上彻底清除。它在一些城市仍然合法，即使在纽约，它也没有完全消失。
It just moved into CD underground establishments. Meanwhile, the game designers were still developing new features. The most important of which were the flippers that first appeared in 1947 that allowed you to swap the ball around the playfield by pressing two buttons on either side of the machine. In other words, the flippers gave you some control over the outcome of the game. Remember, when pinball machines were first banned, the games were considered a game of chance.
它只是转移到了地下的秘密场所。与此同时，游戏设计师仍在开发新功能。其中最重要的是1947年首次出现的脚蹼，它允许你通过按下机器两侧的两个按钮在游戏场地上交换球。换句话说，脚蹼让你对游戏的结果有了一些控制权。记住，当弹球机最初被禁止时，这些游戏被认为是机会游戏。
You'd basically put your quarter in, pull back the plunder, and hope for the best. When the flipper was added to the pinball machine, it should have changed the game's legal status. It wasn't a game of chance anymore. You could finally control the ball. If only they could find some way to prove it. Ladies and gentlemen, I give you Roger Sharp. I guess at one point I was considered to be, if not the best player in the world, one
你基本上投入硬币，拉回柱塞，然后祈祷好运。当脚蹼被添加到弹球机上时，它本应改变游戏的法律地位。它不再是机会游戏了。你终于可以控制球了。如果他们能找到某种方法来证明这一点就好了。女士们，先生们，我向你们介绍罗杰·夏普。我想在某个时候，我被认为是，如果不是世界上最好的玩家，也是
of the best players in the world. Nearly 40 years after the introduction of the flipper, in April of 1976, Roger Sharp was called upon to prove that pinball was a game of skill before a meeting of the flipper. In April of 1976, Roger Sharp was called upon to prove that pinball was a game of skill before a meeting of the New York City Council. On the day of the hearing, tensions were high. It was packed, a lot of camera crews. The New York State Coin Operated Amusement Game Association had arranged for the hearing and they'd hauled two pinball machines into the meeting room. One that Sharp was to play and another that would serve
世界上最好的玩家之一。在脚蹼引入近40年后的1976年4月，罗杰·夏普被要求在纽约市议会会议前证明弹球是一种技巧游戏。在听证会当天，气氛紧张。现场挤满了人，有很多摄像组。纽约州投币式游乐游戏协会安排了这次听证会，他们把两台弹球机搬进了会议室。一台是夏普要玩的，另一台将作为
as a backup in case the first one suddenly died. And I started going over to the game that had been designated. The council had been pretty antagonistic to Sharp. They thought he would cheat. And right before he was supposed to play, a council member stopped him. He said, no, not that game. That game over there.
备用，以防第一台突然坏掉。我开始走向指定的机器。市议会对夏普相当敌视。他们认为他会作弊。就在他准备玩之前，一位议员拦住了他。他说，不，不是那台机器。是那边那台。
I think that the head of the city council thought that that game was somehow rigged. Let's go with the game that's been turned off that nobody's paid any attention to. That's over there in the corner. The council session took a 20 minute recess so that the camera crews could change the lighting from the original machine to the new machine.
我想市议会负责人认为那台机器被动了手脚。让我们用那台关掉的、没人注意的机器吧。就在角落里。市议会休会了20分钟，以便摄像组将灯光从原来的机器调整到新机器上。
And then Roger Sharp steps up and starts playing. Back then I was able to really show off. So it was very nice to be able to call my shots and just do whatever I wanted to do. Baking back hands and shots for right to left to right. And then for the grand finale, Sharp wanted to prove that even the first shot, the one that involves just pulling back the plunger and letting go, that even that shot can be perfected with skill. So he turns to the council members and says,
然后罗杰·夏普走上前开始玩。那时候我真的能炫耀一下。所以能够指哪打哪，随心所欲地做任何我想做的事，感觉非常好。反手击球，从左到右，从右到左。最后，为了压轴戏，夏普想证明即使是第一杆，也就是只涉及拉回柱塞并松开的那一杆，即使那一杆也可以通过技巧来完善。于是他转向议员们说，
If I do this right it's going to land right down the center. Pull back the plunger, it went up and blown straight down the center. And the guy was out of the seat and kind of threw up his head. That's it. And I was right, I was ready to keep on playing. I was having fun. City Council voted 6-0 to pass the legislation. Sharpe has said in the past that he got lucky with this shot.
如果我做得对，它会正好落在中心。拉回柱塞，它向上飞去，然后直直地落入中心。那个人从座位上跳了起来，有点惊呆了。就是这样。我是对的，我准备继续玩。我玩得很开心。市议会以6比0投票通过了该法案。夏普过去曾说他那一杆运气好。
But now he says that he was being modest, that his blunge was not luck. To do what I did, that was skill. To have done it the way that I did it was pure naivete. Within a year, pinball was legal again in most places across the country. But not in Oakland and Alameda. Where as we heard in the beginning of the show, pinball just became legal in 2014. Even with the rise of video games,
但现在他说他当时太谦虚了，他的柱塞操作不是运气。做我所做的事，那是技巧。以我那种方式完成它，纯粹是天真。一年之内，弹球在全国大多数地方再次合法化。但在奥克兰和阿拉米达没有。正如我们在节目开头听到的那样，弹球直到2014年才合法化。即使随着电子游戏的兴起，
the pinball industry continued to experience waves of success until the 1990s, but over time, people lost interest. The last big corporation to manufacture pinball machines lost millions of dollars on its pinball division and decided to shut down in favor of a more profitable operation, making slot machines for casinos. After decades of fighting to prove that pinball could be a game of skill, it turned out that the most lucrative bet for game makers was on games of chance, gambling machines. You know, ballies casino, they used to be in the pinball business, and they took their name from their first hit pinball machine manufactured in 1932 called balliehoo. Welcome to the 21st century.
弹球行业继续经历着成功的浪潮，直到20世纪90年代，但随着时间的推移，人们失去了兴趣。最后一家制造弹球机的大公司在弹球部门损失了数百万美元，并决定关闭，转而从事更赚钱的业务，即为赌场制造老虎机。经过几十年的努力证明弹球可以是技巧游戏，结果证明游戏制造商最赚钱的赌注是机会游戏，即赌博机。你知道，巴利赌场，他们曾经从事弹球业务，他们的名字取自他们1932年制造的第一台热门弹球机，名为“巴利胡”。欢迎来到21世纪。
In 1999, Pinball tried to make a comeback with a game that integrated a video screen on the back glass with a mechanical play field. Welcome to Pinball 2000. Welcome to the new image in Pinball. Welcome to the 21st century. That was a promo video for Pinball 2000, despite the reverb and the medicine ticking clock and the mountains of hyperbole heaped upon the promotion of the game it never really caught on.
1999年，弹球试图通过一款在背板玻璃上集成视频屏幕和机械游戏场地的游戏卷土重来。欢迎来到“弹球2000”。欢迎来到弹球的新形象。欢迎来到21世纪。那是“弹球2000”的宣传视频，尽管有混响、滴答作响的时钟和堆砌在游戏宣传上的夸张言辞，但它从未真正流行起来。
Which is probably because if Pinball still has any appeal, it's actually the vintage, analog nostalgia feelings it brings up in people. We like it because it's not the future. It's the past. Back in the Pacific Pinball Museum, Mike Shease thinks Pinball is making a bit of a comeback and it's because people are longing to get away from screens and from games that they play at home alone. So with Pinball, you can kind of gather around and watch your friends suck. And that's the other thing that's really cool, is that anybody can suck at pinball.
这可能是因为如果弹球还有什么吸引力的话，那实际上是它带给人们的复古、模拟的怀旧感。我们喜欢它，因为它不是未来。它是过去。回到太平洋弹球博物馆，迈克·希斯认为弹球正在复苏，这是因为人们渴望远离屏幕和独自在家玩的游戏。所以有了弹球，你可以聚在一起看你的朋友表现糟糕。这是另一件非常酷的事情，任何人都可以玩得很烂。
I mean, it's a great equalizer. You don't have to be smart, you don't have to be physically an athlete. I think what he means is that anybody can suck and anybody can be great. It's a nerds game, a rebels game, an underdog's game. One of the best pinball players in the US right now is a young guy with autism who can memorize the geometric patterns that the ball makes on the play field. And then of course there's that deaf dumb and blind kid I heard about once. Never saw him play, but I heard he was really good.
我的意思是，这是一个伟大的平衡器。你不必聪明，你不必是身体上的运动员。我想他的意思是任何人都可以玩得很烂，任何人也可以玩得很棒。这是一个书呆子的游戏，一个叛逆者的游戏，一个失败者的游戏。目前美国最好的弹球选手之一是一个患有自闭症的年轻人，他可以记住球在游戏场地上形成的几何图案。当然，还有我曾经听说过的那个又聋又哑又瞎的孩子。从来没见过他玩，但我听说他真的很厉害。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Mickey Kapper and Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan, Avery Truffleman and me Roman Mars. Mickey did another piece about pinball and its roots in Chicago for a program I love called Curious City. It's not really like just a show, it's this news gathering experiment based at WBEZ where people submit questions about Chicago and Curious City investigates and imports it's genius. We'll have a link on a website. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW
本周的《99%隐形》由米奇·卡珀和凯蒂·明格尔制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马斯参与。米奇为我喜欢的一个名为“好奇城市”的节目制作了另一篇关于弹球及其在芝加哥根源的报道。它不仅仅是一个节目，这是一个基于WBEZ的新闻收集实验，人们提交关于芝加哥的问题，“好奇城市”进行调查并报道，这真是天才。我们会在网站上提供链接。我们是91.7当地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，
in San Francisco and produced of the offices of ArcSign and architecture firm in beautiful downtown, always law abiding Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible, you must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio.
位于旧金山，在美丽的市中心、始终守法的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市的ArcSign建筑事务所办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。广播塔皮奥。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。